we have fox team coverage tonight
alexandria hoff with more on how
lawmakers are reacting and we begin with
mark meredith in wilmington delaware
where president biden is spending the
weekend mark
molly good evening to you it has been
quite a day a war of words breaking out
between the white house and a fellow
democrat west virginia senator joe
manchin who as you mentioned told fox
earlier today he will not be supporting
the president's social and climate bill
better known as build back better
mansion telling fox he believes this
measure is not only too expensive but
simply goes too far
i've always said this brett
if i can't go home and explain it
to the people of west virginia i can't
vote for it
and i cannot vote to continue with this
piece of legislation i just can't i've
tried everything humanly possible i
can't get there you're done this is this
is a no
this is a no
up until this weekend the white house
made it seem like it was likely that
they were going to be able to reach a
deal with mansion now it almost is hard
to believe it but the gloves have come
off the white house is ready to fight
mansion publicly in a statement released
today by the press secretary jensac she
writes senator manchin's comments this
morning on fox are at odds with his
discussions this week with the president
with white house staff and with his own
public utterances saki goes on to say
quote just as senator manchin reversed
his position on buildback better this
morning we will continue to press him to
see if he will reverse his position yet
again to honor his prior commitments and
to be true to his word while we have
heard from white house staff we have not
yet heard from president biden on camera
he didn't hold any public events today
while in wilmington he's going to be
going back to d.c tomorrow i would
imagine plenty of reporters will be
shouting at him on the south lawn trying
to get some sort of reaction but the
administration is also dealing with
another crisis and that is coveted the
pandemic impacting cities and states all
across the country we know that the
president is going to be delivering an
address on tuesday we don't know what
time yet talking about what the federal
government can do to help many places
that are
struggling right now to keep up with
what's going on molly mark meredith
thank you very much no shortage of
things for the white house to focus on
right now thank you
on capitol hill now senator manchin's
announcement resulting in anger on the
left and delight on the right alexandria
hoff with more from washington on
lawmaker reaction
lawmaker reaction ranges from relief on
the right to the left where some still
think that mansion could be swayed and
on the far left his decision is being
taken as pure betrayal we all knew that
senator manchin couldn't be trusted
you know the the excuses that he just
made
i think are complete progressives say
they predicted that the massive spending
bill would fall apart once it was
decoupled from the bipartisan
infrastructure bill congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez tweeted maybe
they'll believe us next time
congresswoman corey bush said this
having those coupled together was the
only leverage we had and what did the
caucus do we tossed it while the dispute
among democrats continues republicans
are expressing gratitude for manchin
knocking down legislation that the cbo
determined would cost upwards of four
and a half trillion dollars
republican senator lindsey graham said
this quote i very much appreciate
senator manchin's decision not to
support bill back better which stems
from his understanding of the
congressional budget office's analysis
of the bill the reality is the
overwhelming majority of the congress
knows that this bill is crazy even
though there are six or seven them that
only say in private what joe and kirsten
sinema say regularly in public
democratic senator bernie sanders wants
to see a vote take place even without
mansion support if that is the case that
i hope that we will bring a strong bill
to the floor of the senate as soon as we
can and let mr manchin explain to the
people of west virginia why he doesn't
have the guts to stand up to powerful
special interests manchin said today if
lawmakers want a vote on the bill to
show where they stand then they should
hold one hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else